hi my name is Simon and I'm a PhD
student at the University of Exeter and
if you've watched my videos before you
might know that I have struggled in the
past with my mental health specifically
like a lot of students I struggle with
my mental health around the exam and
revision period recently I got to sit
down with Josie Josie works at the
university of Exeter's well-being center
and we were able to talk for some time
about issues like exam anxiety and
stress about adapting to life at the
university at start of the year and also
general student well-being throughout
the academic year lobbying center here
Exeter is fantastic but it's indicative
of services that are available in
universities and campuses all over the
world
so if any of the issues that we talk
about in this video have affected you
and they think might be relevant to you
I'd highly recommend that you get in
touch with your campus well-being and
mental health services
honestly I regret every day that I
didn't get in touch with my services
sooner when I was going through my
difficult period this is the first video
of hopefully of quite a series where
we're gonna be talking about these
issues and to begin with iOS Josie what
exactly well-being meant so well-being
is one of those kind of umbrella terms
which I suppose is just used quite
generally but well being at University
we think of well-being as those in terms
of health and our emotional and mental
health which can fluctuate just like our
physical health can and there are going
to be certain times at university where
maybe we're not going to feel so well in
ourselves so I suppose that's why we try
and use the term well-being rather than
mental health because it's not always
about mental health difficulties so what
kind of services then to your students
okay so when at the well-being centre
Exeter we have a number of different
options we have various different
psychological therapies available such
as cognitive behavioral therapy
counseling we have different groups and
workshops as well just as a way of
giving people kind of strategies and
ways of coping
so workshops on things like stress
fasting exam stress busting
procrastination perfectionism the kind
of common things that a lot of people
kind of go through mindfulness we do a
kind of group on mindfulness and
compassion so they're the sort of
therapeutic kind of thing
that we do then we also have mental
health advisors that work for us as well
and basically they can work with
students that have a diagnosed mental
health difficulty where it's been going
on for longer than a year and it impacts
on their course and study and they can
look to make any kind of reasonable
adjustments that might make it kind of
more might make their the time at uni of
those students more manageable so if
there's certain things which are
affected by their mental health problems
there might be some adjustments that can
be made that might make that a bit
easier
whether that's some kind of extensions
or specific exam arrangements and some
students might be eligible for the
disabled students allowance as well
which is a certain amount of money which
can fund them their support for the
University say they might be able to
have access to a mentor which is a
mental health practitioner that can work
with them on an ongoing basis that can
focus on things like study and you know
working towards it and deadlines and
things like that so it's not just really
serious the kind of things that the NHS
for it's a range of services is not it's
it's the entire spectrum of people
feeling you know getting down to two
medical conditions yeah it's it's much
broader than a lot of NHS services which
are more specific or uncertain kind of
difficulties and presumably you get an
awful lot of students that come to you
with this kind of thing I mean it's not
a rare thing for people to come to
campus services for these things
oh no we we have a lot of demands here
don't resent it so free room yeah
through ten times we were always really
busy and to be honest the what we can
offer fluctuates as well depending on
our demand at different times of year so
people we shouldn't feel that they have
to wait for how their food reaches
certain level of severity before they
get in contact they should they
shouldn't feel that they have to be a
certain level of you know mental health
before they feel you can help them would
you say they should came to contact as
soon as they think there might be a
problem yeah I think it's it's always a
lot easier to kind of work through
problems that earlier on they're kind of
identified and we do have different kind
of levels
support here as well so you know
sometimes we do get students contacting
us saying oh I feel like I'm wasting
your time and I'm sure you've got people
that are far worse off that you need to
see and that's absolutely not the
message that we want to be giving
because actually it can be really
helpful to kind of intervene a lot
earlier with those difficulties before
they get too out of hand and you know
more difficult to manage do you think
people should just chance it and even if
they feel like they're being silly
just getting to contact just to touch
base with well being yeah I mean what we
do here is we can offer kind of 15 10 15
minute telephone call treehouse
appointment so even if a student wanted
just to talk to someone to just see what
you know a practitioner thought and what
kind of support there might be available
they don't have to take it any further
if they don't want to but at least it's
the chance to get in contact and speak
to somebody and just get some advice on
you know what different options are
available so if in doubt just get in
touch just get in touch yeah so really
there's no there's no time not to get in
contact basically if anybody thinks that
they are kind of really struggling and
like I say it might just be a matter of
coming in and having a single session
with somebody because what we do here at
Exeter which may vary from university to
university is we don't just offer kind
of counselling or cognitive behavioral
therapy